the search continues for a missing
two-year-old boy in las vegas
amari nicholson has been missing since
wednesday may 5th he was last seen near
the area of paradise and twain
today 8 news now spoke with his father
about those search efforts
victoria saha joins us live from a
community search party that just began a
few hours ago
victoria sasha nevada child seekers is
still here with their tent handing out
flyers with amari's picture on it right
by
emerald suites where amari was last seen
two-year-old amari
went missing wednesday from emerald
suites his mom taylor nicholson says
she was out of town and left amari with
her boyfriend who was watching amari at
the time
but when we spoke to him yesterday he
says someone claiming to be the
toddler's aunt
came and took the child we spoke with
amari's dad today who made the drive
from reno to personally get involved
with the search
just give get my son over that's not
your son
it's my son and her son just give him
over i just want him safe
i just want him found and we i just want
answers
volunteers with nevada child seekers say
they're willing to do anything to get
the word out about omaree's
disappearance
but when it comes to the average citizen
just helping this is what it's about
we had people come here just on their
own already organized
our agency we're here helping as well
and we work with the families we work
with law enforcement and we're hoping
that somebody will just call and tell us
what they know if they've heard anything
if they saw him
the group made about one thousand flyers
with amari's picture on it the group
will be here until
seven tonight and amari's family is also
offering a 30 thousand dollar reward for
his safe return
i also want to add we did speak with
metro police yesterday
they are actively searching for omaree
as well
live from emerald suites victoria sahav
8 news now